hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 3rd 2017 a day before July
4th over there when you guys doing it oh
Jesus Christ what are you guys doing it
you're partying tonight you got to go
tonight right you got to go tonight and
tomorrow you like a fat [ __ ] but tonight
is tonight tonight tonight tonight
tonight if you want to go out and get
[ __ ] hammered you know tomorrow's for
the kids you know today you scare your
children tomorrow you wake up with them
that's how it works when July 4th is on
a Tuesday you know your wife will give
you dirty looks but you know by the
weekend as long as you're mulching up
the [ __ ] Yad she'll be happy what do
you want committee I celebrating the 1st
of the nation they're not the movie you
[ __ ] racist cake well you made me
curse you know he get involved in those
stupid things anyways oh man Oh Billy no
fun was Billy bad boy this week I
completely just [ __ ] I just I don't
know what happened I went off the rails
I went off the rails I was flying out I
was doing the Capitol Theater in Port
Chester there's were almost amazing
venues I don't know what it is about it
this is one of those places and it's got
the [ __ ] magic in it you know and
that's been around forever and according
to the people that ran it he was saying
that Janis Joplin played there and in a
bar nearby or something she wrote that
song Mercedes Benz tried it out for the
first time at that venue then went out
to LA recorded it and then overdosed
that was it and I was like that's great
well you know what I'm not gonna be
trying any new material this weekend
don't birch write out a new dick joke
recorded it onto his iPhone went back
into the city had two slices of pizza at
3 in the morning followed by four shots
of [ __ ] whiskey and then
went to bed died on a futon yes he was
alone oh my god I just I don't happen I
was flying out there I think I was
stressed I don't know what it was and
then the guy you know asked me if I
wanted to drink you know I wasn't on
plane it was just at I came up to me
because I you drink I was like I was 13
you can know I was on a plane and the
steward the male stewardess came up to
me so do you want you want anything to
drink right and the devil in me went oh
and I went quivering voice maybe later
so you know I've been eating great I had
salads and all that [ __ ] and I thought
hey you know I'll just have one I'll
just have one he comes over with some
jack on the rocks
you know nice [ __ ] pour right give me
your mile-high Porsche you know what I
mean you he [ __ ] gave me like gave me
like three fingers the [ __ ] booze so
that's with a little bit of pepper and
some cheese and I [ __ ] drank the
thing and I was like guys that's it I
got it I got a I gotta get waters after
this cuz that's the big thing after I
have the first one I just switched the
waters and then then I get my bearings
again I was like oh yeah okay cool okay
cool we had a buzz now we're coming back
we're coming back this is a good thing
but if I go to that second drink forget
it and he just [ __ ] what can he say
do you want and I think he just brought
me the next one and then I was just like
well I'm not going to be rude and then I
drank that one and then then we landed
and that just set me off on the wrong
the wrong [ __ ] way the wrong [ __ ]
Road then I got to the city and then I
got two slices the [ __ ] pizza not
even from a place that I liked place
that I wanted closed because they have
great pizza and they already made their
money so like well we don't need to be
open all night go [ __ ] yourself see yeah
so then I walked down the street to
these other guys you know the one that
all the drunks are stumbling into and
and I got not one but two slices of
pizza went back [ __ ] shoved them down
my throat the whole time going you know
this is way better than anything that I
get in LA but this is not a good example
of how the East Coast became legendary
with their pizza making no disrespect to
Chicago by the way okay I'm not saying
you guys don't make you make a different
type of lasagna pizza out there and most
New Yorkers people from Boston Philly we
go out there we don't know where to go
and we just get some average slop and
we're like the [ __ ] pizza sticks
right the same way you guys I know so
many [ __ ] people from Cabo - Anthony
okay did you pick you look good did you
even look to see where to go
you dope New York has a great reputation
for making great pizza that's why
there's so many shitty ones you know
what I mean because everybody's living
off of that [ __ ] reputation is like a
half dozen probably maybe eight in the
[ __ ] all the borough's how many
boroughs of is it Queens Bronx Brooklyn
Staten Island man of five [ __ ]
boroughs it's probably probably eight
okay Brooklyn's got a couple New York
has a couple everybody else has like
[ __ ] one maybe two I don't know
enough about it but I'm just telling you
there's only a few however in New York
City you can buy pizza every [ __ ] 10
feet down the road same way in Chicago
some [ __ ] [ __ ] is out there waiting
for someone like me to walk down the
street with my [ __ ] Chicago the Windy
City windbreaker that I just bought at
the airport hey I'll genuine authentic
[ __ ] Chicago deep-dish pizza then
they're going to bring me in there so
can we end the [ __ ] pizza debate
everybody you know has their own way to
do it up in Boston they had the little
bar style pizzas which are [ __ ]
amazing and every New York content goes
oh I went up there shaking [ __ ] the
dates like [ __ ] with buoys over there
in the Fulton Street days you know those
[ __ ] morons when you travel okay you
got it [ __ ] hang with local people
and they'll tell you where to go to
[ __ ] walk into a place and think that
every
there sucks and people there just accept
it is probably one of the dumbest ways
to travel however that's how most people
do it or you go there and you try to get
what you can get down the street from
where you live it when you can't you say
this place sucks
yeah I just I can't you know
I was in the bar was that gonna get a
little buzzing gobble hole
anyways I don't know why I'm making
everybody Italian but I'm enjoying it
I am adjoining so so I hit this shitty
[ __ ] pizza and I was taught to finish
my food as a kid so I'm [ __ ] even
just non my way through the crust I mean
I could have whittled something like a
piece of wood with this crust tough like
[ __ ] shoe leather over there that's
what's the first night and then I did
well during the day you know I did
really well but then just at night the
next night I ended up staying up we went
to [ __ ] oh right down the street from
the Porchester Capitol Theater was this
great Italian restaurant and it was all
part of partly owned by Mario Batali
who's the best all this [ __ ]
restaurants are awesome right so I go
down there and I know I should order the
fish but I can't get good Italian out
here so I order I order some pasta right
I get the [ __ ] and go [ __ ] yourself
bowling H right so I get that and then
we say we don't want dessert they still
brought some stuff over because they're
Italian
I mean just you know if you say I don't
want any they're still going to bring
you over a half order that's how it
[ __ ] works so they brought over the
all these cannolis and all of this [ __ ]
and then didn't drink too much that
night but definitely you know not
trigger that much to me was like you
know five or six over [ __ ] nine our
peers they also like 4:00 in the [ __ ]
morning smoked a cigar [ __ ] stupid I
had all this [ __ ] to do the next day
right at [ __ ] get out of the [ __ ]
oboe right I get out of the over and
I know I told you guys I don't do Bert I
had somebody call it for me because I
shouldn't get a cab and I get out of the
second I get out of it I walk over the
door I go oh wait where's my phone
where's my phone and I left it in the
[ __ ] / and then I didn't have I had
no no way to call and I was like you got
to be [ __ ] kidding me because I had
my bag of [ __ ] with me so I grabbed my
bag and I got this thing once I grabbed
something I never looked for anything
else and also you know I had like
[ __ ] four or five drinks so I left my
[ __ ] phone there until it's just like
alright it's good a mental check
everything's backed up everything's on
the computer gives a [ __ ] I'll just buy
a phone tomorrow [ __ ] [ __ ] right so
I get up the next day I go over to the
[ __ ] Verizon store and they go okay
what's your Apple ID I'm like I don't
know you got my phone number here's my
license no like oh that's not good
enough you need your Apple ID
I go why I don't have it he goes can you
guess oh yeah you're [ __ ] standing
all day I don't know what it is and he
basically tells me that he can't get you
can't get into my account without my
Apple ID I go you're telling me if the
FBI came in here right now that's what
you'd say and he was like absolutely and
I was like - I don't know what it is are
you telling me I can never get a phone
again this feels like a Tom Cruise movie
did you just shut off the microchip in
me can I can I get a phone please I
business to do the guy says no I haven't
been meditating my temper starts going
up and up and up and up and up I didn't
curse Adam I started you know he goes
well you're gonna have to go to our main
store and that's going to take like
[ __ ] two to three hours so it's like
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me so I
walk out into the streets in New York
and I said I [ __ ] hate technology but
I said I really quietly in technology
really quietly but [ __ ] I said to talk
my lungs [ __ ] when I [ __ ] hate
technology this lady [ __ ] whip their
head around I was like oh my god I'm
like I think I'm literally the guy
walking in the street in New York making
people nervous right now so I walk up to
try to find with his [ __ ] places I
don't know he said it's on like [ __ ]
50 something and 6th Avenue I'm looking
for the thing and I'm wait wait is it on
six thousand on 57th I have no idea this
took me back to the 90s when I was in
York when you didn't have a map but you
just [ __ ] walked around head on a
swivel I finally find a place and I
walked in there and I got an absolute
angel at the store
old-school customer service completely
[ __ ] hooked me up and she was like in
her mid-20s halfway through I just
finally was just saying like you know I
forgot I said it so something you
basically the effect that you know you
don't get customer service like this
anymore your parents raised your right
she said thank you I go to come from a
big family and she was like I was like
sense I'm like I'm like one of seven I
was like I know it I know it I know it I
don't know one of these kids who come
from like [ __ ] with a bunch of kids
families with a bunch of kids that I
don't they learned it I don't know what
I don't know what you learned but you're
I don't know everything isn't about you
and you keeping all the [ __ ] toys so
she totally hooked me up and then then I
was able to call my buddy who called the
uber called the uber guy and then the
uber guy still had my phone he brought
it back to me the next night you know I
gave him a nice tip for doing that and
now I got two phones I guess I can bring
the other phone back but I just don't
want to go back into a story I'm not
rolling the dice again then I'm going to
get a good customer service person I
know I'm not
so I'll just [ __ ] eat it was my own
[ __ ] fault I didn't go out til [ __ ]
4:00 in the morning like an [ __ ]
none of that [ __ ] what had happened I
apologize to the lady that I made her
[ __ ] probably [ __ ] up her neck when
I scream [ __ ] when I was out in the
street and but you know I don't
apologize to the guy at the bank I owe
taxes right I owe taxes up in [ __ ]
Canada so an account goes you have to go
to the bank I'm going to send you an
email with all the [ __ ] account
information they can wire it up there
bing-bang-boom done
so I say fine so I go up they download
the thing I bring my laptop I [ __ ]
get this David Blaine looking dude you
know at the bank to help me out right so
we walk into his cubicle area we sit
down I have all the information on the
computer screen he says go I
the VI n number I know it's not that but
you know what I mean I'm like what what
nummies like that number there read that
to me so I read it to me goes I read me
the next time I go because read me that
number then I just find look if I go I
go what do I work here it's like excuse
me I go I go I feel like I work here
right now I'm like I look just just
turning around here here's all the
information typing in he goes what's
going to go quicker or something like
then then you just kind of get quiet
right I'm just [ __ ] sitting there and
then after a couple minutes he just kind
of goes like you know I don't understand
like why you got upset there I go okay
I'm not upset I'm just calling you out
on the fact you start treating me like
your secretary I don't work here because
I'm not treating it get sick today yeah
why you got me like reading off numbers
and stuff because I'm just doing that
cuz it'll be faster I go well I disagree
well what the [ __ ] am i you you you
understand you work at the bank you're
at the bank you work at the bank you get
paid to work at the [ __ ] bank I'm the
customer this is what I need you to do
do the [ __ ] transaction jesus [ __ ]
christ these [ __ ] God day I'm going
to say it these kids today everything
about them it's interactive hey man like
hey you know [ __ ] reach out from the
[ __ ] interwebs man [ __ ] off and do
your job
I didn't say any of that I just said I
disagree that's the best I could do but
I just couldn't he was like 50 what
kills me if he's walking around saying
that I'm a day which I am I admit to
that but I'm [ __ ] right I got to sit
there and read off [ __ ] numbers to
you he goes can you read this any would
say please
he's such talking to me like I'm like I
was like I'm glad you get hired as your
assistant you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't even know what he was talking
about all of those numbers I'm not a
[ __ ] banker every time he told me to
read off the number he had explained
what the number is like how is that how
is that quicker ah Jesus so I meditated
for the first time above six weeks
I'm just trying yeah I know I know
I just I'm back we're back in the
writers room I got all of that [ __ ] to
do I'm building my new [ __ ] act right
my daughter is finally sleeping through
the night you know she still wakes up
once or twice but it's just a quick
little one maybe needs a diaper change
or something like that and I'm just
feeling like it's just it's building up
again you know so for me now to like
stop drinking you know to add that that
extra stress of like you know you know
to not have the [ __ ] thing to take
the edge off at the end of the goddamn
day like that it just starts building up
so up to the guys the bank maybe I could
have explained it a little nicer maybe I
couldn't just flipped out here but you
know no this that's what I wanted to say
in the bank but I didn't okay I just
[ __ ] kept my cool but like you work
at the bank I don't I need you to do
this transaction I have money in your
bank back in the day you guys used to
give like 10% 8% on [ __ ] money in the
bank you now give like point one zero
zero zero one percent okay so now you
don't give me any money on it you've
alone ten times out on what I [ __ ]
have there you guys invent money you're
literally counterfeiters and now I have
to go in there you guys nuke the [ __ ]
economy every eight [ __ ] years
building housing bubbles or whatever and
you don't go to jail for it and you
leave Americans upside down in their
houses you don't give a [ __ ] and then on
top of that I got to go in and read the
[ __ ] numbers off to you [ __ ] off I
know this is childish for me to be
sitting here alone losing my mind but I
cannot lie to you and not tell you how
[ __ ] good this feels to get this out
of me you know part of my meditation
today is I'm actually doing this series
on patience swear to God and the guy
said oh god what the [ __ ] did he say it
almost made me mad when I was like I
wanted to debate with the guy but I
can't because it's just a recording he
basically said that when you lose your
patience it's because you have
expectations of other people
okay and then when you react to that
it's like your fault for reacting to it
for having your wrong to have these
expectations of people and I'm thinking
in my head like like that doesn't make I
like I'm at this point I'm wrong that I
expect people to put in an effort at
their job the way that I do and the way
that I did and I'm not patting myself on
the back but when I [ __ ] I always any
job I had I [ __ ] killed it unless I
just literally didn't have the talent
like construction I just I mean I could
bring you the [ __ ] I just didn't have
that gift or I tried to sell health
insurance I just wasn't good at it and
you know what I did I had the decency
with both of those jobs to quit within a
week and a half
I didn't [ __ ] sit there and torture
people and just suck at my job as they
came walking in or worse try to make
them do part of my job so I'm listening
to this guy and he's talking in a very
soothing voice like this some sort of
British accent when we all came there we
have headspace that again welcome to
headspace when we have expectations of
other people gives us the tendency to
and tries to like let loose a patient I
don't get all [ __ ] jolly because you
know it's you know what it is he's doing
that because he knows there's an angry
[ __ ] like me laying on the ground going
like okay so now you're defending this
guy at the bank
you weren't even [ __ ] there you know
so now basically what you're saying is
in order for me to have patience I have
to basically treat people the way I
treat my daughter which is I understand
that she's a baby and doesn't know
anything yet
you know so I have to have 100% patience
with her which I do but that's because
she's a baby
so now I'm supposed to walk in and sit
across from a 27 year old guy in his
you're going to like the way you look I
guarantee it [ __ ] suit and as he
tells me to do what how could I have
done that better I guess what I should
have said is sir
I don't mean any disrespect but I'm not
going to read those numbers to you I
feel that you work at the bank and I am
the customer and I feel that that
crosses a boundary that I'm not
comfortable with I guess I could have
said that right and I when he exhales I
probably shouldn't like when he exhales
like it was like someone [ __ ] twisted
a knife in my back I wanted to [ __ ]
she's like did you just [ __ ] exhale
yeah because once again I guess I had
expectations that this guy you know I
had the ability to [ __ ] look at a
paper with all the answers to the test
on it while typing at the same time I
mean I can do that I could do that for
half a page and I only make a couple of
mistakes and I taught myself how to do
it what the [ __ ]
how much more easier does life have to
be and then I was also thinking when I
left I was like you know something my
wife would have just read the numbers
off to him she would have read the
numbers off to him and then afterwards I
would have said like why did you just do
that he did job she goes well you know
you're right you're right you know I
probably should have done that but you
know it got it done quick you know I
just and one of the argument bla bunch
continues on you know and she's a way
way happier person on paper I think on
paper I know do you know something thing
about women is the big red flag is the
level of shopping that they do and the
amount of [ __ ] that they buy like that's
I don't know this is it there's a
[ __ ] unhappiness there there's
something psychotic going on with just
the amount the sheer amount of clothes
and [ __ ] that they buy and just stuff
that they [ __ ] buy
I don't see tranquility in it I feel
like that's like eatin [ __ ] you know
these candies just they just love having
that UPS driver showing up and oh it's a
little package for me you know I
actually judge how well my relationships
going by how often the [ __ ] UPS
driver comes to the door if he's coming
a lot then I need to take her out to
dinner or something
if you know he's coming every once in a
while then that's just her doing the
woman thing of basically you know
[ __ ] kicking our retirement right in
the seeds I didn't did I'm smoking
whatever I apologize to everybody I
apologize that first guy [ __ ] Verizon
store I apologize for the way I conveyed
what I was trying to say to the to the
David Blaine look and dude at the bank
you know I don't know maybe it's a new
world maybe I'm just a [ __ ] old guy
maybe that's why I don't [ __ ] know I
don't know I still think I'm right but
I'm going to learn in the future and not
to have expectations of people and just
sit there is the end of my life slip
away waiting for somebody to do their
[ __ ] job if they get paid to do
anyways anybody watch some moto gp
[ __ ] motorcycle race yesterday
another great one back to back [ __ ]
great races congratulations to my
Marquez oh my god did you hear his
[ __ ] interview afterwards
that was [ __ ] hilarious first of all
it's amazing all these guys can speak
English but he searches for the English
words while go in the ass he did too
[ __ ] one so [ __ ] long they go mark
congratulations great victory blah blah
blah the blood and feel of death today's
that it was bad
many of that have minded me and Taylor
Negron great rested pieces great joke
when if you don't want carpet you want
an ad remember the area rug joke anyways
what a [ __ ] race and I can look at
the standings here I think that that put
mark mark has cheese he's on top he's on
top of the leaderboard the lead of Ford
board sorry Marc Marquez [ __ ] I'll
come on you don't have expectations
don't have expectations of the internet
that it's actually going to work why
would it work why would it work when you
would need it to work just laugh make a
note of it make a note of a difficult
time in your life put it on the
clothesline and send it on down and stay
just remember you're not reacting you're
observing you're just such as sitting on
a park bench watching traffic go by
except the trafficker are your thoughts
oh look the requested URL cannot be
retrieved I'm going to have no reaction
to this I'm just going to sit here and
let my podcast slowly sink into the
abyss of something completely not even
remotely funny alright here we go
where the [ __ ] are we by the way you
know this [ __ ] website stinks because
you think if these guys are [ __ ]
putting their lives on the line it'd be
a little easier to navigate weight away
does that mean having [ __ ]
expectations again alright
Marc Marquez is in the lead 129 points
was just what the points that they got
from yesterday oh this looks like from
what they got yesterday congratulations
to that kid maverick VIN we'll bill Nez
is that the guy though I thought he was
German I don't think I have the wrong
guy this might be the wrong list it says
GP world standing there was some guy
that came in second place it was the
first time he's ever been on a podium
this year
hold on a second this is so [ __ ]
irritating where is it they haven't done
that one yet how about this one
deutschland there we go see I had the
wrong one I had the one now where the
[ __ ] is he thought there was some German
guy that came in second yesterday since
Dani Pedrosa from Spain came in so
whoever the [ __ ] the guy was that came
in second congratulations I actually
learned something when I was watching
the race as far as just how I made you
guys come flying down the straightaway
there in the Tuck and I love when they
all they [ __ ] pop up and they stick
that goddamn leg out right have we still
even got a fall off the bike at that
point and then it's all when you brake
how you take the turn in this kid who
was in second place came in Jose I think
was turned one and he just came in too
hot which caused him to go wide and Marc
Marquez did it perfectly and he just
went right underneath them and but I
guess you guys said something to the
fact that he heated up his tires when
you brake that hard or something and you
don't get as good a grip and that was
basically what do they say something he
not creates a space or something but he
broke away from where he broke them or
something I'm still learning the
terminology but they're [ __ ] amazing
you guys got to get into this MotoGP
because this thing is little it's 28
[ __ ] laps and you watching people on
motorcycles driving 200 miles an hour or
320 kilometres which I've learned every
50 miles an hour is about 80 kilometers
so I always have to do the [ __ ] math
but it's easy because they're basically
doing well like like I don't know like
240 to 320 kilometres except when
they're in the turns obviously so they
basically go on about a hundred fifty
miles an hour 140 all the way up to like
200 the Italian wants the crazy one with
this the straightaway where they
actually get up over 200 miles an hour
I'm a just and their ability to fall how
they fall even fall off the bikes
gracefully and let's say high side them
and then the technology of the suit
where there's like an airbag in the suit
that immediately detects that you've
fallen off your bike and inflates that
protects your vitals
and then the leather is just such
high-quality or whatever they got they
just slide down the track and they get
up dude big [ __ ] wipeouts at 200 miles
an hour and they get up like they fell
up a tire swing at a cookout [ __ ]
unreal so congratulations to Marc
Marquez I'm a big Ducati fan so I like I
root for the [ __ ] I root for the
Italians you know I like that guy what's
in it you know it was great it's that
guy from Britain though who's actually
in a Honda that Cal Crutchlow he [ __ ]
rides like a maniac I also like yo handz
arco he's from France he rides a Yamaha
but uh the video so I like I just love
Ducatis I think they're a [ __ ] work of
art but if you ever wondered how much
those bikes cause I think they were like
worth like two million dollars those
bikes something like that a million two
million bucks there I love when they're
going down the straightaway and they
[ __ ] given so much throttle that the
front tire comes up a little bit you got
to stand at that point you're going 200
miles an hour and you don't have you
been that's split-second you don't have
the ability to steer when your tire is
off the ground the [ __ ] balls that
those guys have I stopped riding a bike
because I couldn't write you know but
actually know something probably riding
the streets of LA in your [ __ ] dad
jeans with your leather jacket on that's
waving that is way more dangerous I
don't have a [ __ ] airbag five I get a
motorcycle again I want to buy one of
those MotoGP [ __ ] suits but the thing
about it is is even if you fall off even
if the [ __ ] the thing like inflates
and all that [ __ ]
the difference is is that the track you
don't have to worry about somebody
coming in from the left of the right
driving a bus or an SUV and running you
over and crushing you that's basically
it because I have to say I would love in
a perfect world in a perfect world I
would love I would love to have a Ducati
I've never ridden one but everybody know
they have the road one said you never
ride everything else I mean so with it
like I'm a black I said I'm a big fan of
[ __ ] machines and there's one on
visit out here in LA and LA Sienna got
this
one right right up the streets from this
vegetarian place when I'm not being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and eating shitty pizza
and drinking booze and smoking cigars
like an [ __ ] I'm eating right when
every time I go there I always got to
pop in there and then the guys Oh ed can
I help you I just want to be like nah
just a scared married guy with too much
to lose just around you I'm going to say
that next time I come in they're going
in this so many times the guy probably
knows me all right let me read some of
these maybe read some of these
advertising advertisements here Oh give
me a loot crate everybody be the envy of
your friends and get a hundred percent
exclusive crates at loot crate calm
slash bur and enter my code Barbie you
are are to save $3 off on any new
subscription July's loot crate theme is
animation like ethics or family on a
quest for epic gear housewares and
collectives loo crate has it loot crate
offers an epic range of pop-culture
items for less than $20 a month if
you're more of a fanatical fashionista
then try out loot where I have no idea
what English it is Luke to me is money
and a crate is a giant [ __ ] box that
is like lifted up with machinery
I don't offer expires July 19th at 9
p.m. Pacific it's in July's loot crate
you'll find items from Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Bob's Burgers love that
show future around I love that show and
Rick and Morty which I heard is great I
haven't seen one lucky subscriber will
also win a mega crate of serious epic
proportions you have until the 19th and
9 p.m. Pacific to subscribe and receive
that month's crate and when the cutoff
happens that's it it's over
go to loot crate calm slash burn enter
my code birds say $3 off on any new
subscription today and lastly but not
leastly movement watches talk about your
personal experience with your watch I
like that my watch listens to
me I feel like for me when I put on a
movement watch people respect me more
the company started by the company
started by two broke college kids I
always loved that we're broke let's
start a company how does that work they
wanted to wear stylist watches but
couldn't afford them so they started
their own watch company because God
knows start your own company cheaper
than buying a [ __ ] watch how is it
this like your how is this like how you
started build a following launched into
a podcast YouTube radio etc I think sex
same way except I didn't even anything
other than gas money
I commend these two Broke college kids
that were able to start their own
[ __ ] company I don't know how you did
that
how I've started everything in my
business is I always worked for free for
a long [ __ ] time and that eventually
made some money and I had some [ __ ]
thrown at me on the way up
movement watches started it just started
just 95 dollars at a department store
you're looking at four to five hundred
bucks you know why because they got paid
for the overhead of the store we would
figured out that by selling online they
were able to cut out the middleman in
retail markup providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction and style the minimalism
get 15% off today with free shipping
with free returns by going to movement
calm / / this watch has a really clean
design seriously I've been getting
compliments ever since I put it on why
do they do that
I guess I'm supposed to read it before
you I don't even know why I don't have a
movement watch on me right now I gave it
to Andrew he [ __ ] loves it and I bet
he's getting complex right compliments
right now I have a watch I don't know
where it is
alright so I'm not getting any
compliments on my [ __ ] freckled
wrists now it's time to step up your
watch game go to movement calm and VMT
dot-com join the movement o / bar join
the movement
alright okay all things comedy oh here
we go all things comedy my comedy
network which is producing its first
stand-up special starring Trenton New
Jersey zone Paul virzi it's going to be
taping August 13th alright tickets are
going
you're going to want to be there me and
Pete Davidson are going to come out and
do a little Smothers Brothers [ __ ] up
front I think we're just going to go up
with a notebook and try out new material
and just [ __ ] on each other's new jokes
where everybody's gonna have a good time
then Paul's going to come out absolutely
crush it I have to tell you he killed so
[ __ ] hard this weekend up it uh what
the [ __ ] is it called Porchester
the Capitol Theater I told them on the
first night I said dude you're
officially not a [ __ ] opener anymore
the level of laughs that you're getting
and the quality of material that you're
doing it that's it you know that's it
he's going to be a [ __ ] nationally
[ __ ] selling out headliner soon and
I'm going to mess up all things comedy
has launched its own patreon page to
give you exclusive access to podcast
videos and a behind-the-scenes look at
our latest projects go to
patreon.com/scishow podcast paint you
got to see patr yo and patreon.com slash
all things comedy I did a Sunday vlog
before Monday video I actually had a
great time doing it al madrigals new
podcasts secret of my success in the
first episode features Felipe Esparza
all right they talk about everything I
wanted to talk about ok talk helicopters
for a second so I got back into flying
those [ __ ] I fly once a week I have a
great time and last week I feel great
you know I just you know I didn't really
have to look down at my altitude I was
just able to maintain it pull in 19
inches on the [ __ ] [ __ ] inches
gauge they would have a [ __ ] he call it
I so I'm getting ready to solo again and
you know it's the [ __ ] Hobby cost a
goddamn fortune so I was sitting that
thinking like you know buy a helicopter
where the [ __ ] X just you know to get
really good at this
like that I love it so oh my daughter's
crying she must just woke up anyways um
so the one I'm not gonna say the name of
the one that I don't even I've said it
before okay there's just certain things
with the design of that thing it's a
two-bladed main rotor system it's over
slung and semi articulated all this
[ __ ] ground school [ __ ] but basically
because of that if you were for whatever
stupid [ __ ] reason if you slam the
stick forward and got yourself into a
Logie situation which is basically you'd
feel like you were late in the seat like
there's a chance that you do risk mass
bumping you risk shearing off the tail
you risk [ __ ] with the mass bumping
the main rotor literally spinning off
you watch it eh there's that thing
that's producing lift right and then you
just crash to the ground or if you get
into a Logie situation literally the
[ __ ] thing could just start rolling
to the right because the rear tail rotor
is now compensating for the [ __ ] main
rotor that the helicopters not loaded
underneath anymore so when you go to the
right rather you think oh my god go to
the left with the stick you're actually
supposed to go gentle gentle as you're
[ __ ] rolling over like holy [ __ ] I'm
not going to be upside down in a second
rather than go back to the left you're
supposed to [ __ ] override that
intuitive move and you're supposed to go
gentle as cyclic so you don't share your
[ __ ] goddamn tail off and you know
people with very little hours all the
way up to people with a ton of [ __ ]
hours have died in those [ __ ] things
and the company that makes them rather
than fixing that [ __ ] problem has
just basically told people what to do
when that problem arises and if you
don't do it correctly and you [ __ ]
die they blame you you know so it's a
lot like being in a relationship with a
woman in that it's always going to be
your fault it's not what they did it's
how you reacted to it so you know in
order to get the a fully articulated
main rotor system
where you can [ __ ] basically as my
instructor said fly like an [ __ ]
which is stab to think forward you know
I don't think that any of them you
really should be doing any sort of quick
[ __ ] movements I don't think quick
movements in any aviation is never
[ __ ] good unless you're getting shot
at and you're in a [ __ ] f-16 but any
sort of mass bumping Logie none of that
boat that's all taken off the table and
but the problem is is to buy one of
those they're like well over a million
dollars so that kind of bugged me so I
just kept doing my research and I found
this French helicopter I'm going to say
it wrong it's guin ba l guy humble
kibrit g2 and it's a little more
expensive than the one that I fly it has
a fully articulated main rotor system
and then all these other features I
forget what you call it when when the
the tail rotor is completely enclosed
you know one of the major causes of
death is like people walking into the
[ __ ] rear tail rotor they just I
don't know they just don't see it this
is why you have a passenger you have to
tell them to stay in the [ __ ] thing
until they shut it off because I still
don't know how you walk into a fan
that's making that much noise but they
do it they solve that they got like
these I don't these rubber [ __ ]
bushings and all this [ __ ] that you know
like if you land you're not going to
turn your [ __ ] spine you have a hard
landing you're not gonna turn your spine
and the goddamned you know gunpowder
I really should wish I had the article
here all of this [ __ ] that they had it's
basically they looked at what I flew and
they addressed everything and then for
next day you know half a bag a cache you
can fly this thing and not have to deal
with with any of these [ __ ] safety
issues and I looked it up and basically
the only problem with it is because it's
so safe now people are flying like
[ __ ] and they've had three of them
crash and one of this one of the guys
that crashed and I don't laugh
if they died or not but what they did
still a carbureted engine right so you
can deal you know you always have to
pull your carburetor here because you
don't want the [ __ ] it freezes up on
you the engine shuts off and you know
you don't have to know a lot about
aviation that that's not a good thing so
what this [ __ ] guy did was to show
somebody that this you can [ __ ] stab
the stick forward he stabbed it forward
and started like nosedive and down and
because of the way the fuel line was it
caused not enough fuel to be going
through the carburetor and he [ __ ]
stalled but why do people do that if I
ever got one of those things I would
still fly it the way I fly the [ __ ]
thing that I fly now
and I would just feel lucky that you
know God forbid if I was ever flying and
I hit some turbulence that cause you
know the helicopter to [ __ ] nose over
or something like that I don't have to
worry about me rolling to the right and
having to remember to slowly go aft
cyclic to [ __ ] reload the thing I
mean actually affects like where I fly
out here the time of year like I won't
go out into like the [ __ ] desert or
something like that during the tsavo
because I don't need all that [ __ ]
turbulent air throwing me around knowing
at any second I could start rolling to
the right I just don't want to deal with
that [ __ ] so I find this [ __ ] thing
now the only downside that I found
there's always the downside right is
that this thing because it's European
the main rotor actually spins the other
way which I didn't think would be that
big a deal but what it actually does is
is all my muscle memory is for a main
rotor that goes counterclockwise this
spins clockwise so all the times when I
think left pedals now right pedal but I
talked to my instructor he said it's
about three hours and you start getting
it down and then you're fine but then
you know three hours I mean three hours
they get to fly in a helicopter I have a
great [ __ ] time and then I just keep
flying the same one every time then I
get it down then I have this really safe
thing that I can fly around got a little
compartment you can put stuff in it's a
little [ __ ] two-seater check it out
GUI and be al-kibriya cabr IG - I mean I
think that the [ __ ]
there's always concerns with any [ __ ]
new helicopter whatever but I just feel
like it addressed all the safety issues
that [ __ ] you know anytime I solo I'm
just thinking about that which is good
because I had you know the guys at
training were great so I'm always
thinking about that [ __ ] and but you
know you read up on it a lot and it
becomes like this [ __ ] terrifying
thing that I really don't feel like I
don't feel like dealing with so I don't
know I just you know you want to really
which I just wish [ __ ] schools around
here start buying those things so I can
rent those instead because I mean it's
still too much money it's too much
[ __ ] money but I'm just saying you
know in a fantasy world I would have one
of those and I'd write a ducati to it
with an air bag suit on and it'd be no
bus to run me over if I have a [ __ ]
laid it down but we all know that that's
not the case so you know maybe I'll just
get a poster and put it on the wall in
my garage
that's what being a married guy you
garage you have a poster of all this
[ __ ] you'd buy putting other
responsibilities now god that's that
that actually made me a little sad
alright F I know this is some people up
in Oregon that sell them I believe they
finally they got I guess raided over
here whatever the terminology is but I
[ __ ] love them and it's a great
looking helicopter - I [ __ ] love them
and I'm hoping whoops I'm just giving
them free advertising hoping more people
start to use them alright f-18 Billy Boy
Mercedes has 1500 people working on two
cars simultaneously 1498 of which
probably went to prestigious colleges
and graduate schools of none of which
gets to race these cars the two
employees that raced these inverted
rocketship cars hated school as kids at
least Lewis Hamilton admitted to it your
thoughts Oh what did the Tom Brady gets
all the [ __ ] credit well yeah
absolutely this is like white hidden
figures
sssss the end of the day the person that
gets in the [ __ ] rocket you know be
it the monkey the dog or a [ __ ] human
being who gets in the thing and actually
[ __ ] rides it you know what do you
want those 1498 people of Lewis Hamilton
had a fatal [ __ ] accident they have
the luxury of walking around away from
it feeling bad that it happens whereas
Lewis would be dead so that's why he
gets to bang Rihanna I mean I don't know
what to tell you I thought you were
going to explain why the Mercedes team
and the Ferrari team are so much you
know better than everybody else but on
the more I read about f1 it seems like
people go through phases like I said Red
Bull won three years in a row McLaren
used to be the [ __ ]
martini Williams had their run so I
don't know maybe this is just the era of
the Mercedes and Fernando Ferraris been
doing [ __ ] for a long time obviously God
it's the biggest understatement ever
I'll never forget the look on that guy's
face when I said when I said good race
after Montreal when they came in like
eighth or he came in like fourth just
watching the guy go from available from
the back all the way up to almost a
podium is what I was trying to say and
this guy [ __ ] looked at me I thought
it was a dead man anyways because lots
of luck at count basie theatre I hope
you kill it
will not be in attendance due to you
guessed it school ciao alright father
and son circumnavigate navigating globe
in a helicopter well how the [ __ ] do you
do that you have to go up to Alaska
cross over to Russia I got to see this
hey Bill thought you might find this
interesting Canadian father and son are
circumnavigating the globe in a
helicopter here's a link to the article
oh that's nothing about that helicopters
it can fly up to like five hours whether
one I fly I mean two and a half hours
and then you put it on the ground so
I don't know it's [ __ ] amazing oh now
look at this I got a copy and faces like
stay patient let's just just note this
thought here you're sitting on the bus
watching the trip I'm on the bus I'm
sitting on a bench waiting for a bus
watching the traffic going by oh come on
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
is it that difficult alright take off a
helicopter father-and-son team begin
global Odyssey - look at that [ __ ]
helicopter holy [ __ ] Wow yeah these guys
are the real deal though do they get
sponsors look at their [ __ ] flight
suit Bob and Steve Dengler embark on a
39,000 kilometer trip around the world
to celebrate Canadian history and
support charities that's kind of
annoying - flying to your country to
celebrate and canonical [ __ ] yourself
celebrate the world of fly around us for
a year and a half my father Bob and I
have been planning and organizing a
journey we call C 150 global Odyssey it
was it's the first Canadian
circumnavigation of the globe by
helicopter and the world's first ever
father-son aerial circumnavigation I
don't give a [ __ ] about all this other
than your plan oh here we go here we go
oh you know what I guess they're cool
with Russia they're cool with Russia so
they're but I don't know where they're
going to get a start the start-finish
but looks to be somewhere in the Toronto
area all right so they're going to
zigzag across oh they're going the other
way they're going to Zig over over to
the [ __ ] Maritimes
up to [ __ ] Greenland Jesus that's
[ __ ] scary right there over that
[ __ ] ice cold water then Greenland of
[ __ ] Iceland how long is that flight
Iceland over the [ __ ] Ireland down
into Perry cross Europe across [ __ ]
no I'm sorry England that's England
there okay and they go across to Eastern
Europe then right through Moscow to
Russia right back over to [ __ ] right
across over to Alaska and then they come
back down to Vancouver up to [ __ ]
Yellowknife for whatever [ __ ] reason
I guess to celebrate in Canada you have
to go over those [ __ ] Rocky Mountains
do that's scary we started running our
first stop is the Canadian aviation and
Space Museum in Ottawa where a grand
send-off is plan from there we fly east
along st. Lourdes to do fund I guess I
go to read this instead of trying to
guess with their map north of one the
case of Labrador take equal LeWitt
equality East Bend through Greenland and
Iceland and the Faroe Islands to the UK
then through Europe and into Russia a
full third of our trip is through Russia
exclamation point they're excited
because the Canadian they get along
people we return to North and North
America via Alaska and then zigzag in
Canada to visit as many places as
possible we finish up back in Vaughan
taking 35 to 40 days in total will be
flying some of the far most far-flung
and beautiful places in Canada and
drinking deeply from its diverse beauty
oh that's nothing to boos I think you
guys are nuts
urban skylines Arctic seas when saw you
[ __ ] it god bless these two what a
great [ __ ] thing to do more
importantly what kind of helicopter is
that that's a fully articulated rotor
system no [ __ ] rolling over the Reg
and dad live India oh holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] amazing I want to keep up on
them when do they say they're doing it
starting July 1st they're already off on
their wake what can I follow it do like
a dad and son Amelia Earhart except
they're going to make it right all right
well good for them what a helicopter
talk this week all right
here we go weird new co-worker hey Billy
hold your nuts I might have gone over
the line at work and want to know your
or Nia's input would be would be on this
okay long story short I essentially quit
my job today because the co-worker was
taking pictures of me before you jump to
any conclusions hear me out and you
might agree with me and our deal I don't
like that somebody's taking it sounds
like you didn't want your picture taken
this Monday we got a new employee that
basically acts like she's in a reality
show the first day I thought she might
be joking around by doing the classic go
from one person to the next and whisper
turning around talk about the other
employees in the room okay go from one
person to the next and whisper turn
around talk about the other employees in
the room because she's already talking
[ __ ] about everybody but then I realized
she's just crazy she has taken pictures
and videos of all the men at work and
shared them with her snapchat or
Instagram or whatever crap it is she's
uses to communicate with other people
that are on her level sounds like she's
trying to get a reality show herself
have become famous or something the
first time she did this she was standing
a few feet away from me and did a 180
jump spin that would have made Dennis
Rodman proud with the phone took a
picture and said that one was for
Instagram it startled the hell out of me
and I plainly said don't take pictures
of me over the day she continued to take
pictures of the rest of the guy without
consent of course and I got to see a
couple of them one was of my bosses
asked with the text over it that said
dead booty though oh god this is yeah
this is something just spends too much
time on the internet I don't know why
you quit your job you should just go
into function you guys just go to HR so
the only thing that god finally got me
was when I was restocking the shelves
and realized after walking across the
store that I felt I was being watched I
looked up and saw her grinning while
holding her phone and I asked her if she
had taken a video of me she said she was
taking a video of the rain outside and I
happened to walk across the path
obviously [ __ ] I called her Bluff
and asked her to show me the video from
the beginning and it's clear that it's
Arsen ends with me 20 seconds of me
Wheeling merchandise around you can
barely see a window on the back where
you can't even tell it's raining she's
standing 60 feet away from the [ __ ]
window alright now before you say ah
maybe she likes you dude I'm on your
side and wants to see you let me be
clear no one is touching themselves to a
video of a guy with a dad bod wheeling
around merchandise it's not that and she
knows I'm happy in my relationship with
my longtime girlfriend regardless I
complained to my boss who up to two days
finally talk to her about it and then
she told me she said I walked in front
of a rain video she was making I said if
it was the other way around and it was
the guy taking videos of women I'm sure
that would have been grounds for
dismissal absolutely I also forgot to
mention that she went through my boss's
text when he wasn't looking to see which
women were talking to him it pissed me
off that he was more than willing to
believe that she was suddenly a
part-time meteorologist than just
believing me that it was the fortieth
video of that kind she was taking though
so I kind of snapped and told him not to
bother insulting our intelligence by
trying to believe his excuse and I said
if she tells him the picture of his ass
wait and I said if she tells him the
picture of his as she took was intended
to be a picture of morning fog until he
got in the way to just keep it to
himself and I quit
ah dude you snapped you snapped you know
why sorry dude I got the volume up to
her you know why your snaps because like
me you had expectations and you lost
your patience and that caused you to
lose your [ __ ] mind and you know what
you're a hundred percent in the right at
least I'm hearing your side of the story
here so what do you think did I go too
far that I've given her time to adjust
I'm sure you deal with unwanted pictures
of you every day but I'm not famous and
haven't done anything to deserve this
yeah I mean exactly that's it I mean
you're not jumping around like a monkey
on stage I feel like I'm being followed
by the worst P I and I can't
helping it gives me anxiety as far as I
know she's already has pictures of me
with the eyes cut out at home the way I
see I'm not wasting time waiting until
the co-worker grows up to learn the
difference between right and wrong she
happens to be 19 but I'm talking about
mental maturity because I've worked
alongside teenagers before who know
perfectly well what the appropriate way
to believe to behave at work is and this
job pays lousy enough that it's no big
loss as far as I'm concerned thanks and
hope you and Mia have a little and the
little one have a good 4th of July you
guys are a plus to em as far as I'm
concerned thank you very much um I agree
with you hundred percent the only thing
is she's 19 so I think they just need to
talk to her I wish you didn't quit your
job but it sounds like you're not really
worried so I don't think it was your
dream job I mean maybe her behavior open
the door for something you got to turn
it into a positive and you also have to
learn like I'm trying to learn my
behavior and Verizon in the [ __ ] bank
this week you know I you know what it
was was you asked her nicely she ignored
what use what you you you asked her not
to do you went to the person of
authority and he swept it under the rug
and then that was enough to make you
[ __ ] snapped I completely understand
that I think your behavior is completely
normal
I'm surprised you didn't tell your boss
to go [ __ ] himself and but at the end of
the day you know you don't have a job
now so and you're actually a good guy I
mean I what did the guy say when you
quit he was alright with that I think
kids grow up today and they because they
so overshare on all of these things
their boundaries with privacy is pretty
much non-existent I mean it was like a
famous woman took video of an older
woman naked in the locker room going oh
my God look at her old ass she got it's
like like she had no idea that why would
you do that to somebody but somebody's
mom and their grandmother but I don't
know people are
it's bad and I gotta be honest it's bad
enough when someone comes up to you and
just takes a picture you don't want them
people walk up with the video already on
[Music]
yeah yeah I don't like that and even
with what I do because you know they're
usually extremely selfish person and the
whole moment is about them and you know
that whole oh man Yolo
look at my life right now shaking my
head whatever the [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] that
they're doing it really is funny that
when you watch these [ __ ] kids on
like Instagram and everything
everybody's acting like they have like a
hit show and that they're like these
celebrities themselves like always
taking like you know snapchats for the
pictures of like the food they're eating
the car that they're in the [ __ ] view
that they have everybody's like acting
like I don't know but they're flying
every time I act like that flying around
a [ __ ] private jet I don't understand
it
but I'm also I'm realizing that I'm
[ __ ] old so I don't know I don't know
I think I think you reacted in a normal
[ __ ] way I wish you didn't quit your
job though because I think you're a
hundred percent right in the future I
would just go to HR and when you're
would go to your boss when he doesn't I
would make a formal complaint and that
would stop it and but I know I would
know at that point that I would hate
that 19 year old so much that would be
hard to even be around her like I have a
big I have a big issue with forgiving
people like once you're in in the [ __ ]
column head kid you know it's kind of a
life sentence so there you go yeah move
on with your life I just kind of learned
from that [ __ ] but a good for speaking
up but I don't do anything else don't go
back to the [ __ ] business like a
lunatic [ __ ] key somebody's car or
anything they just [ __ ] walk away
from it all right girlfriends
opportunity a Billy Red Wings
so my girlfriend is really doing well at
work she's been offered a job in
Switzerland she would rather move in
with me and stay in the United States I
feel that she's missing out on a great
career opportunity and should go I love
her but I'm not in love with her yet
she's also considering leaving her job
to I like our relationship and I'm more
article you should take advantage of
things that come across your life what
are your thoughts my thoughts are you
don't have the balls to break up with
her and she's committing to you in a way
that you're not prepared for and you
need to break up with her and tell her
to go to Switzerland and that quitter
[ __ ] job that was an easy one
I love her but I'm not in love with her
yet and you're going to fund she's going
to quit a job and move in with you
because she's head over [ __ ] heals
well boy do ya so I go to Switzerland
and [ __ ] some blue-eyed [ __ ] specimen
a blue-eyed blonde Ian specimen forget
about you all right girlfriend wants me
to change my name dear bill I'm going to
I'm a huge longtime fan of yours from
the younger generation f ones F ones for
family is oh f is for family gut I can't
read my name on my own [ __ ] that's an
eye f is for family is [ __ ] awesome
can't wait for season 3 to come out to
see what happens next well thank you
I was obvious in this situation I've
been a relationship with a wonderful
young lady for over two years now we met
at a community college in my state and
hit it off really quickly she's smart
outgoing beautiful community college
easy hey hey hello what the smart thing
there all right no kidding a lot of
smart people go to Community College
they do they just [ __ ] scatter bring
a lot of dopes go there too
she's smart outgoing beautiful head lion
has a great sense of humor she's tall
slim black girl while I am a greasy
haired Italian white guy and we get
along great the problem first started
with my dad he's a total racist and
since we can he can't we can't afford to
put me in a real university I have to
live with them I've tried to get him to
change his ways but it's like you said
in your act old men like him come from a
different era so there's probably zero
chance that whatever changes money can
change somebody's mind they got they
have to want to I told my girlfriend how
frustrating is with him and she
understands that even though my dad
hates her and doesn't want us to be
together that I'm nothing like him at
least where it counts even though I
can't stand my dad's attitude I know
that Eilen wants the only wants the best
for me so I try to be a good boyfriend
and a good son while keeping my father
and girlfriend separate from each other
we also spend time out at her or out at
her place
Joey comes over to my place my father is
on a business retreat enix crisis is
complex it's really inconvenient but
we've been making it work for over two
years in spite of the tribulation and
we're still going strong
it seems like I got everything figured
out alright Jesus this is a [ __ ] long
one seems like I got everything figured
out bill but here's where things get
tricky since I'm his firstborn son my
dad named him after himself
since same first name middle name and
last name my girlfriend hates that the
guy she's been in a serious relationship
with for a long time has the same name
as a cantankerous old racist a go lucky
being racist about yourself greasy
Italian [ __ ] anyways who hates her sexy
black ass for no justifiable reason
Jesus Christ
it sounds like bad [ __ ] dialogue in a
porno she wants me to legally change my
name completely first middle and last so
that there is no connection to my father
whatsoever when I asked her what name
she thinks I should have through this
effect I don't believe this you gotta be
[ __ ] me she said I could change my
last name to the same as her her name
last name parenthesis what the [ __ ] I
told her that if it would make her happy
I would be willing to change my name but
if I did that my dad would feel betrayed
he would hate her even more for stealing
away stealing only son away from him and
the rest of our family think I'm a total
trying to disassociate myself from them
which is totally not the case she got
upset with me and has given me regular
reminders since then that she's serious
about wanting me to go through with this
this isn't the first time I've
considered changing my name even before
I started dating this woman it's a very
Italian sounding name so what you're
very Italian that people always made fun
of me for it throughout schools so I've
come to dislike it myself yeah dude you
got a lot of self-loathing going on here
tines are the [ __ ] who makes better food
than you huh
Japanese know this you guys make like
the best food in the [ __ ] planet the
Ferrari you Ducati you [ __ ]
the Mediterranean lifestyle doll what
are you walking away from here so bill
what the [ __ ] should I do here how can I
make things right with my girlfriend as
well as my dad without accepting one
party or the other she stopped
introducing me to people using my name
and she only refers to me as my
boyfriend I've been able to circum
circumvent hostility between my dad and
my girlfriend before but I've totally
I'm totally lost with this one any
advice would be very much appreciated
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself sincerely
that's funny any [ __ ] leaves his name
is a deal to eat first of all this isn't
about your dad and this isn't about your
girlfriend this is about you okay you
date who the [ __ ] you want to date and
your name is your [ __ ] name and your
heritage is your [ __ ] heritage all
right
like what what if her [ __ ] her
parents didn't like you because you were
white and you said okay you're named
after your mom I can't stand your mom
change your [ __ ] name and I'm going
to pick the name and it's not going to
sound like you know I guess black people
don't have their [ __ ] death nicknames
anymore do they thank you white people
but you know what I mean yes [ __ ] that
dude you can't do that [ __ ] you can't do
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that your name is your
name
and you're Italian and you should be
[ __ ] proud of it okay and you're not
your dad and she needs to [ __ ] accept
that you're not changing your [ __ ]
name and she has a problem she can
[ __ ] walk away she can [ __ ] walk
all right you know what you really need
to do you need to get out of your
[ __ ] house and you need to [ __ ]
build your own life okay anything you
need to be with somebody like this is
[ __ ] nuts like I gotta tell you dude
like that if you thought about [ __ ] that
came from you that's one thing but the
fact that she [ __ ] wants you to do
that that's [ __ ] insane don't do it
you know you're you're giving in to
everybody else and you're not you not
staying true to yourself you got to
figure out what the [ __ ] you want and
you have to be yourself
change is [ __ ] christ man your dad is
who the [ __ ] he is
your girlfriend is who she is and you're
who you are okay and you should be proud
of who the [ __ ] you are
work on the stuff you need to work on
and be proud of your heritage and I
don't I don't get I don't [ __ ] get
that at all you know I know I know
number of people like Italians there we
got to to Italians down her name who
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ] I don't understand
like I don't I don't I wouldn't do that
I miss all the [ __ ] ethnic things
everybody that homogenized their [ __ ]
names I think it's interesting when you
meet somebody that's like that so I
think you need to pump the brakes here
sir
all right because now it's getting
[ __ ] crazy and yeah don't do that to
your dad don't change your [ __ ] name
who gives a [ __ ] he's an old crabby
[ __ ] racist this is the deal dude
he's going to die someday all right
and you're going to continue on so what
you haven't done yet is you haven't
created your own life you're still
living at home with this guy so you have
to [ __ ] move out all right the name
he gave you is the name that he [ __ ]
gage you don't change it because of his
stupid [ __ ] thoughts okay embracing
the [ __ ] you are and if this woman you
can't [ __ ] deal with it a little walk
tell it a [ __ ] walk you young there's
plenty of fish in the [ __ ] sea you
know Jesus Christ you're going to
[ __ ] bend over that far you've you
bendin over backwards flip you like your
[ __ ] gymnast you know when they do
those things - hands foot hand foot hand
foot all the way across the [ __ ]
diagonally across the goddamn mat [ __ ]
that [ __ ] all of that you know I liked
your girlfriend at first by the end of
this [ __ ] thing I didn't like her
okay because she's waging war with your
dad through you and your innocent all
right you're the guy taking her out for
a [ __ ] ice cream why do you got to do
all this [ __ ] ya know I mean Jesus
Christ that whatever the her tell you to
change your [ __ ] name would be you to
tell her to go get it can you get a go
like a weave like a blonde weave or some
[ __ ] like then what the [ __ ] you got to
be able to [ __ ] you are god bless you
you tallien son of a [ __ ] stay true to
your word stay true to your [ __ ]
name continued not to be racist and
[ __ ] just be yourself change your
[ __ ] name ah Jesus Christ
anyway all right that's the podcast for
this week I'll check in on you on
Thursday have a happy safe fourth of
July and if you're not in this country
enjoy your [ __ ] Tuesday
[Laughter]